[Musique]
bonsoir un nouvelle édition de votre
journal d'information locale nous sommes
le mardi 15 novembre et voici les
principaux titres la nouvelle édition de
la job academy ce projet porté par le
club fasse yvelines permettent à des
demandeurs d'emploi de retrouver un
poste explications à suivre le vendée
globe se poursuit les trois navigateurs
et blinois sont toujours dans la course
louis burton vient de franchir le cap
vert et il pense toujours au département
vous l'entendrez et puis la ville de
rambouillet décor du nouveau thriller de
gilles milova série l'auteur nous
parlera pas de son nouvel ouvrage la
faire aurore s entre fiction et réalité
mais tout d'abord quelques mots du
lancement aujourd'hui de peps peps pour
portail espace public service un nouveau
site en ligne proposé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour faciliter les démarches
des particuliers ainsi que les échanges
avec les agents pour michel laugier le
président de l'agglomération cela rentre
dans le cadre de cette nouvelle
politique numérique qui l'a initié avec
ses équipes écoutez le au micro
d'haussmann l'an dernier le peps portail
espace public service va permettre aux
usagers du territoire d'avoir leurs
démarches facilitées alors on va les
temps de bien sûr à la totalité des
services mais on a commencé dans un
premier temps par tout ce qui est
concerne les réseaux et réseaux
assainissement et éclairage public dans
tout simplement les habitants de saint
quentin qui sont face sujets qui
touchent ce domaine là pour intervenir
directement en ligne voilà pour les
propos de michel laugier le président de
saint quentin en yvelines nous
reviendrons dans notre édition de demain
plus en détails sur ce dispositif
emploie à présent avec la deuxième
édition de la job academy avec la
fondation agir contre l'exclusion
l'objectif reste le même cette année
permettra des chômeurs de retrouver un
poste pour cela ils seront parrainés par
des employé es du château de versailles
qui vont les aider durant quatre mois a
augmenté leur employabilité le reportage
de nicolas kirillovitch
une promotion 100% féminine le château
de versailles comme promis lieu de
rendez vous la nouvelle saison de la job
academy a été lancée lundi 14 novembre
une initiative portée par la fondation
agir contre l'exclusion des yvelines sur
le modèle du parrainage une dizaine de
demandeurs d'emploi sont ainsi suivis
par des employés du château de
versailles pendant quatre mois
le premier rendez vous était l'occasion
pour les différents binôme de se
découvrir et d'apprendre à se connaître
cette première prise de contact est très
drôle 1 puisque personne se connaît donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui séduit
énormément ça met à l'aise tout le monde
est là c'est une première un premier
contact voir si ça ce match est tout
simplement et si ça ce match et ben on
fixe le deuxième rendez-vous il s'est
lancé et ça ce match justement entre
amandine et alexandra fille les
marraines vont se donner rendez-vous
toutes les deux semaines avec pour
ambition de permettre à alexandra de
retrouver un emploi le plus rapidement
possible ensemble en fait on va on va
faire en sorte que je trouve ma voix en
fait on va se fixer des objectifs à
chaque rendez vous est donc comme ce
sera ce sera plus carré pour moi et du
coup ce sera plus facile d'aller de
l'avant elle a déjà un parcours
pour moi déjà cadre elle a déjà des
idées quoi qu'elle en dise voilà donc je
pense que ça va être facile
de l'orienter au maximum et puis elle a
quand même un rapport au public qui est
proche de ce que je fais donc du coup ça
va être facile essayez de l'orienter au
mieux pour cette deuxième saison de la
job academy le club face est associée
une nouvelle fois au château de
versailles en plus des rencontres
bimensuelles plusieurs ateliers
collectifs seront également organisés
est dix binômes participent à cette
nouvelle édition soit deux de plus que
l'an passé
culture et demain la médiathèque du
canal à montigny le bretonneux la
médiathèque de saint quentin en yvelines
qui va rouvrir ses portes après 18 mois
de travaux elle va accueillir à nouveau
le public et des aménagements ont été
apportés avec notamment à l'intégration
du musée de la ville au rez de chaussée
de l'établissement musée de la ville qui
lui ouvrira au mois de janvier mélanie
poker
première visite guidée de la médiathèque
du canal ce bâtiment construit sur cinq
étages atone en 1993 la médiathèque du
canal ouvrait ses portes à montigny le
bretonneux
23 ans plus tard elle s'apprête à
montrer son nouveau visage après un an
et demi de travaux les 130 mille
ouvrages ont réintégré ses rayons la
capacité d'accueil de la médiathèque est
plus petit puisque un étage un espace
au rez de chaussée
est dédié
au musée l'expérience de la médiathèque
du petit canal
nous a montré qu' il y avait un intérêt
à accueillir
des publics de différents âges dans
dans les espaces on a voulu également
des espaces
assez mixte dans dans le fait on vient
pour emprunter mais également ses
journées sur place soit pour travailler
soit pour se détendre grande évasion
bouillon de culture la répartition est
envisagée de manière thématique
les plus petits ont leur propre espace
des espaces réaménagés et un
accompagnement du public par les 33
employés de la structure on a fait un
document mode d'emploi de la médiathèque
pour donner à lire un peu le bâtiment
donc un plan et puis ce qu'on peut
trouver dans chacun des étages voilà
pour avoir déjà un premier repère donc
ça c'est forcément un document qu'on va
distribuer et puis y aura également des
collègues au moins jusqu'à fin décembre
qui vont être là en plus des postes
traditionnels des services publics pour
justement accompagner les gens allaient
au devant de répondre à leurs questions
on l'a vraiment les accompagner dans le
nouveau bâtiment en fait elle la
médiathèque du canal accueille près de
17000 personnes chaque mois ses portes
se rouvriront le mercredi 16 novembre
et puisque nous parlions de la
médiathèque parlons à présent de
littérature avec un thriller qui prend
pour toile de fond la ville de
rambouillet l'écrivain gilles milova
série s'est inspiré de ce lieu pour
écrire la faire aurore est ce un récit
qui mélange histoire d'amour et meurtres
en série nicolas d'andré est allé à sa
rencontre
la mairie de rambouillet transformé en
qg pour la gendarmerie le café lieu de
rencontre entre les personnages c'est le
décor choisi par le romancier gilles
milova série pour l'intrigué de son
thriller la faire aurore s le capitaine
marc butz prix
capitaine cédric dernière pour
travailler ici au premier étage et qui
conserve lire donc à centraliser toutes
les informations
blood l enquête pour attraper le tueur
en série une histoire d'amour entre
grégoire mercier et aurore sarde est
inspiré de la vie privée de l'auteur
j'ai milova série et sa compagne
incarnant ses héros
voudras part d'une histoire vraie
lorsque je suis arrivé dans les épi
c'est la première vie quand j'ai visité
avec avec la fabula vient donc ce le
premier endroit où on s'est posé en
garant émission café de la mairie
une atmosphère sombre règne dans la
forêt de rambouillet le tueur en série
rôde dans ces bois pour commettre ces
meurtres la fiction rattrape la réalité
ce livre il ya une partie est réel une
partie fiction et
pour le lecteur c'est simple il suffit
de lui en jeu laissant embarquer par
l'histoire il y aura aucun problème
origine de ce livre un faux mail de
séparation reçu par gilles milova série
le 17 juillet 2016 on a subi une rupture
par obligation et au final je voulais
lui faire comprendre directement en
écrivant ce livre que je ne l'attends
que
je le dis toujours que je suis là le
livre est née une nuit d'angoissé léger
j'ai sorti le free lors de ma tête en
quelques instants très très rapidement
j'ai commencé à écrire le 31 juillet est
gelée terminée dans la nuit du 16 au 17
août c'est à dire exactement trente
jours après le mail de rupture dans
lequel je n'allais pas cru c'était une
réponse symbolique tout simplement
le romancier a entamé une série de
dédicaces dans les lieux d'un trip du
livre il saura notamment le 27 novembre
prochain au café de la mairie à
rambouillet
nous restons dans cette commune de
rambouillet mais pour tout autre chose
la ville accueillait le week-end dernier
la 17e édition du pari fermier c'est un
marché de produits frais fabriqués par
des petites d exploitation de toute la
france d'ailleurs l édition de cette
année est centré sur l'agroécologie les
images de nicolas landry et le
commentaire d'anne-laure l'anguille on
va pouvoir traire la vache donc ici la
traite et mécanisée c'est un appareil
qui va prélever le lait de la vache sa
part elle s'appelle une griffe à traire
c'est ce que je tient dans la main qui
n'a pas un jour rêvé de devenir
agriculteur et des a sans aucun doute
effleuré l'esprit des petites têtes
présentes le week-end dernier au marché
du pari fermier à la bergerie de
rambouillet des étoiles plein les yeux
les enfants sont repartis instruits vous
avez le croyait de rando traiter les
vaches pour faire les
[Applaudissements]
bons baisers que la manne en face il ya
des matchs est extrait poret
ch le pari fermier ressemble fort à un
mini salon de l'agriculture depuis 17
ans outre la traite des vaches on y
apprend à soigner à ns et poneys ou
encore à dresser des chiens de berger
c'est hyper intéressant du coup pour les
gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude de voir
des fermes ce que c'est il ya pas mal
d'animaux différents avoir après les
tables direction le marché où une
centaine de producteurs avaient monté
leurs étals rillettes confiture
saucisson d'autruche tous les produits
vendus ici le son en circuits courts ils
proviennent directement des
exploitations
je propose des terrines à l'autruche 1
puisque on transforme tous nos produits
nous mêmes des terrines du saucisson la
base d'autruche de l'andouille on a une
clientèle très fidèle je compte les gens
veulent se réapproprier leur
alimentation souhaite connaître
l'origine des produits le clown est si
possible les producteurs qui les ont
élaborées et donc on a effectivement
dans ces dîners ricains on est vraiment
dans le vent de l'histoire on a des
précurseurs pendant trois jours les
yvelinois ont pu découvrir ou
redécouvrir la fabrication maison de
certains produits et goûter à des
nouveautés une pause enchanté avant le
retour au supermarché
bois d'arcy a rendu hommage aujourd'hui
à l'aviateur brésilien alberto santos
dumont ce pionnier de l'aviation civile
a vécu dans la commune yvelinoise au
début du 20e siècle pour notamment
expérimenté ces diverses créations après
une rue à son nom c'est une stèle vous
le voyez à son effigie qui a été
inauguré ce matin écoutez à ce propos le
maire de la commune au micro de nicolas
kirilow 8 on a beaucoup d'avenir de rues
de lycées en france qui porte son nom
c'est un illustre inconnu on va dire
j'aurais envie de dire ça comme ça parce
que c'est vrai que il a été essentiel
dans l'histoire de l'aviation française
est essentielle dans l'histoire de
l'aviation brésilienne et c'est vrai
qu'il a fait beaucoup de choses pour
l'aviation et grâce à lui
la recherche avancée la technologie
avancée et c'était vraiment un honneur
pour nous que de mettre en valeur cet
homme célèbre ici à bercy et après les
airs elle la mer on prend à présent le
large le vendée globe 2016 le tour du
monde à la voile en solitaire et sans
escale a débuté le dimanche 6 novembre
après un peu plus d'une semaine de
compétition les trois yvelinois inscrits
au départ de cette 8e édition sont
toujours en course les versaillais
tandis gueule tanguy de lamotte éric
bellion ainsi que le rambo little ou
burton sont au large du cap vert ce
dernier vous a d'ailleurs adressé un
message un peu plus de 4000 kilomètres
des yvelines écoutez le
bonjour les yvelines bon voilà bienvenue
à bord de bureau vallée pour cette
première vidéo pour le vendée globe ça
fait un peu plus d'une semaine qu'on est
parti huit jours exactement on a passé
le cap vert qui est juste là hélas la
météo est plutôt calme et on a encore
trois cent mille avant d'arriver dans le
pot-au-noir là où il n'y aura pas de
vente remise par nord l'hémisphère sud
voilà je pense très bien à vous tous et
puis et puis leur envie de me taper une
entrecôte chez martin commence à se
faire sentir
là lui et bon courage à ces est skipper
les premiers sont attendus dans un peu
plus de deux mois et demi aux sables
d'olonne pour avoir après avoir conclu
donc ce tour des océans un dernier mot
de sport à présent avec la présentation
aujourd'hui à doha au qatar du dossier
paris 2024 premier grand oral pour les
défenseurs du projet face à leurs
concurrents de budapest et de los
angeles rappelons que l'enjeu est aussi
important pour saint quentin qui en cas
de succès se verra attribuer les
épreuves de golf de bmx de cyclisme
versailles de son côté qui va recevoir
est les épreuves d'aviron c'est la
quatrième candidature de la france en
vingt ans verdict septembre 2017 et pour
tony estanguet coprésident du comité
paris 2024 triple champion olympique de
canoë il ne faudra pas se rater fin de
citation et c'est aussi la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi la
rédaction vous donne demain rendez-vous
aux horaires habituels très bonne soirée
[Musique]